let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
welcome everybody this is the tony
michaels and this is gabe sanchez and we
put together the best of the week from
the tony michaels podcast don't go
anywhere stay right here for the best of
the week
that frankly is the point here that
kavanaugh is so
is is so hurt
that people are are saying things
they're saying things in the megaphones
outside my home the truth
the truth that i want to strip away
people's rights
oh
the horror get out of here with that
[ __ ]
i have a special guest for you you know
what time it is
michael popock how are you i'm doing
great
i look very tan am i less tan on the
main screen no no no you're you're fine
you're fine all right okay the painting
looks good everything everything looks
perfect
welcome back to the show you know
i've had your colleague karen agnipolo
kfa here uh several times since the last
time you came and i have to be honest
with you she's much prettier than you
are i know i know a lot of the people in
the chat they call you the silver fox
they've been telling you yum yum yum
this morning that you were coming on
they're very hungry this morning pope
um but but kfa she's she's much prettier
um than you are i do have to say i don't
mean to give you too much hell coming up
back on the show but i enjoy having you
i enjoy having karen from legal af so
tell me what do you think about
this this protest of
of the leaked decision from the supreme
court we should probably start there
since i was just yelling and screaming
about it myself what what is your take
on some of this um these these these
snowflakes being really upset that
they're taking away americans liberties
and boy they really are scared that
they're that they're that they're
protesting about it well uh alito
anticipated
this very thing which is the expression
by first amendment
of of people
and their opinion
about the supreme court voting to
overturn in the first time in 50 years
to take away actually the first time in
the history of the supreme court taking
away a right that they ex that they had
extended to a group that previously had
needed protection in this case women
first time ever and he anticipated this
protest this
proper protest
in the streets when he said
we it does not concern us
what happens
after our decision
that does not
that does not
dissuade us from making a ruling under
the u.s constitution what happens
outside the supreme court does not
concern us okay
well if that's the case
that when people take to the streets and
pick up pitchforks and torches
because of the apparent overturning of
50 years of settled law precedent
constitutional area and the stripping
away of a woman's right to choose a
constitutional right that had been
established not once but twice
it's twice settled law 1973 and 1992 in
the follow-up case of casey
and if they're going to teach
honestly 1992 only really
makes even though it stripped
some of
roe v wade away right it dialed some of
it back
isn't that really in the supreme court
um ruling doesn't that even more
codified into into
the american fabric that that is loved
just by that decision even though it
turned it uh back away from what roe v
wade gave i mean that really having two
decisions is vitally important and it
makes it even harder for them to justify
them reversing it doesn't it the only
just yes and for them to start the
decision
with saying that roe was egregiously
wrong on the day that it was written
right and we're just fixing it now
is really both intellectually dishonest
morally dishonest
and also the scary part tony about the
decision as i've talked about on my own
podcast and a couple of other places the
scary part
is that by throwing away the rule of
precedent
the rule of starry decisis which is the
foundation for the u.s supreme court
since 1807 by throwing it into the trash
can which he does
and he says at one point in the decision
that the
the rule of precedent which is the
foundation for the entire supreme court
and has been since the first decision
that that it has the weakest hold over
constitutional analysis
are you are you effing kidding me to
paraphrase this show right
okay
precedent at the at the constitutional
level
is supposed to be abided by
in every way shape and form and they're
only supposed to overturn precedent if
there's a change in the law or in social
mores since they last expressed the
opinion of the court
as recently as 1992 and what has changed
abortion has not gotten
worse medically people aren't dying from
it there aren't more abortions since
1992 there are less abortions since
1992. there isn't
more people that think abortion are
wrong if anything it has leveled up to
the point where now the majority of
people
are in favor of the woman's right to
choose so if none of those things have
changed since 1992
your your audience might be asking what
did change what changed is they got the
numbers
well yeah well i mean i mean uh money
got changed into bank accounts and
somehow maybe one of the justices uh uh
maybe his name is kavanaugh maybe it's
not i don't know he he got some debt
paid off maybe that's how it works maybe
the federal society you know uh put
their finger on the dial and and really
um we seen this week
that
even clarence thomas
says
oh my gosh this is egregious the the
our institutions are are are being
challenged and people the confidence in
them the person whose wife was involved
in helping helping trying to stoke the
insurrection
is concerned about our institutions
being being
compromised or or the confidence being
eroded are you kidding me is this is
this really the court that we think we
can deal with for the next several
decades do you think that is a do you
think that is the thing that that this
country is going to put up with well the
the gaslighting of america and of
american women has already started
both by the justices themselves with the
horror of the leak and oh my god our
institution is being attacked
um
following up with the republicans this
you know there's a leak of the senate
speaking of leaks there's a leak of the
senate republican committee's talking
points about roe v wade and the
overturning of the decision come the
election which is not the mothers and
the babies we won't go after the mothers
and the babies this doesn't remove
abortion as a choice it just returns it
to the states the states where 23 of
them are automatically going to remove
this as a right that is the beauty of a
constitutional right a constitutional
right is never supposed to be removed
and the rug pulled out from under you
because it's a constitutional right
lindsey graham took to meet the press or
one of the sunday morning news shows and
said oh it was never really a right it
was a it was a it's a fantasy right it
wasn't really there
so nothing got taken away this is the
gaslighting of america
and when you and then continue that that
thematic and they know no shame and they
know no i there's no such such thing as
irony to have ted cruz who refuses to
call the armed insurrection
with the attack on the capital by 800
plus people
he refuses to call that what it is
but the horror
of a few people standing out in front of
a supreme court justice with a bullhorn
oh my god that is violence
oh my god
how could we ever survive in under
america where people were loud oh
oh my gosh how could we ever survive
listen don don we like to involve some
of the the the comments here and don
here is oh he's a favorite uh hate
watcher here he said tony just accused a
justice of taking bribes that's going
too far hey hey don hey don i want to
remind you that the justice that i am
that people out there have have
accused not me i'm just repeating what
people have said
people are saying don
what i'm what what you're saying that
i'm going too far is that i'm repeating
that maybe a justice took a bribe but
what not going too far is taking away
women's rights that same justice that i
am not accusing of taking bribes i'm
just saying that there's some stuff out
there in the uh the ecosphere
i'm saying i'm saying to you that it is
much
much way too far that a debt justice in
particular would take away a woman's
rights with his decision after he told
us he would not do that well continue
continue with kavanaugh as long as we're
on because of your audience we're on
kavanaugh
why is alito quoting kavanaugh half a
dozen times in his own opinion when did
kavanaugh become the expert on civil
rights in america of all things that was
a that was a [ __ ] you from alito of all
the people up there and all the people
that have ever served on the supreme
court including real conservative ones
that i used to respect like sandra day
o'connor like rehnquist and the others
like brent blackman and all the rest
that started out that way he quoted the
guy sitting next to him up on the bench
the one that got um who cried himself
speaking of crying and clutching pearls
who cried himself during his
confirmation hearing because boo hoo
somebody said that he was mean to them
and sexually sexually attacked them
during college that's brett kavanaugh
that's one secondly brett kavanaugh of
all the people who testified under oath
he was the one that probably came
closest to lying under oath because the
others
were very uh were very careful in their
language they all said a version of the
following roe v wade is settled law
roe v wade is they didn't say we're not
going to overturn settled law they just
acknowledge that it is that's like
saying like you know where the polls are
for skiing
and that's also the same thing as skiing
the course the way it's supposed to be
skied no that's just them recognizing
that subtle law he went a step further
he said basically under k as you've said
earlier tony that the combination of roe
v wade and casey 20 years later
renders it a decision a juris prudential
precedent that should not be disturbed
so what happened brett
i looked around you saw you had the
numbers and it's time to clear the
shelves of all the things the federalist
society holds dear let's get right and
then what and what comes next now that
they've if this opinion becomes the
majority opinion which it's going to
this is now an open season open hunting
season to get rid of every
every right that's not written in stone
in the u.s constitution and just to
remind our audience the constitution was
purposely framed by the framers a bunch
of white guys were purposely framed not
to be a code book it's not like section
132.48
of the constitution says this that or
the other thing this is a document that
you can publish in a pamphlet that's
supposed to be interpreted both by the
people its elected officials and the u.s
supreme court and to put and to put
meaning onto the words there and and to
find new rights that's we were taught in
law school in 91 right on the precipice
of casey when i left law school that it
was a living breathing document
that we mapped onto it
changing and evolving social mores like
we're not in favor of slavery anymore we
let like black and white people marry
right we like we let gays and others
love who they want in their bedroom the
way that they want without government
standing there
with a with a flashlight okay
all of those now when you take starry
decisis and you throw it into the
dumpster
and you can say we can do anything we
want we're six people wearing black
robes
if that's the case why do we even need
cases we don't need cases to go up to
the supreme court they can just issue
every week
their edicts
their commandments of what the law
should be in the land right and and for
everybody tony who says let's get a
national referendum on abortion we have
a process for that it's called a
constitutional amendment the problem is
because they have the numbers they only
need to count to five right we have to
get to two-thirds of the senate
two-thirds of the house or two-thirds of
the states they only have to count to
five
five five middle-aged people sitting in
black robes you know at the supreme
court so let's so let me tell you that
that is democracy and i believe in
democracy and um even though
even though it may seem like right now
that the pro-democracy people had their
backs against the walls um that system
of government that you just described is
the thing that will get us to a position
as long as we can get people educated
about what is going on and why it's so
important and there's a few other things
that i want to talk about i'm going to
bring gabe sanchez on because i know he
has a few questions for you too popock
um
but one one thing i do want to ask you
about is
um speaking of states rights because
that's the thing that they do they're
like oh states rights states rights
states rights well the state doesn't
have more rights than the human rights
right like the state's rights don't
overrule the human rights like that's
not that's not exactly how our
constitution was written but speaking of
states rights i was going to say our
study are we going to let south carolina
re-enslave their black population
because well i mean it is the state's
right right it is the state's rights to
let white people own other human beings
i mean if that's what you want to do
then that's what you want to do but we
we had a whole thing i think it was
called um it was a war i forget the
president i forget the war there was a
whole thing we did i don't know it was
it was a while ago you know it's been a
while ago but we did it was it was it
before if it was before two weeks ago
it's well right well right twitter twit
it's not trending on twitter yeah it's
not turning on twitter civil hashtag
civil war is not trending on twitter no
no maybe it should be maybe it should be
but speaking speaking of states rights
states do have some have rights and they
have rights to protect their interests
and we see down in georgia that the
state is protecting their interest in
their election when they're convening a
grand jury what it what is your take on
this grand jury and georgia and i'll
what gabe asked some questions too about
maybe the new york attorney general
exercising her state's rights uh to
protect their interest in taxes so if we
want to talk about states rights maybe
we should actually talk about the rights
that states do have well we've said
we've said on the legal af pod that ben
ben and karen and me too that the the
closest thing that we have to a to a
criminal prosecution of trump
is not going to come from we predicted
this a long time ago karen's old office
at the new york
the manhattan da's office
it i still think it's going to come from
the department of justice through the
grand jury process in washington but the
the one who's quickest to it is fonnie
willis in georgia who now has her
special grand jury in place
uh that's going to be looking at
evidence to make in georgia it's a
little different than other states it's
going to make a recommendation
as to whether there should be an
indictment and the sole issue she's
looking at is one for which all of us
have heard the evidence and it's the
phone call that trump made with mark
meadows to brad raffensberger which
everybody now knows his name pretty well
because of the marjorie taylor green who
who knew who wanted to know brad raffles
burger before that but now everybody
knows him you know he's a he's a poster
child but he's also a republican and
he's running in his own race against a
trump appointed
former congresswoman who's now running
for that position so he's got the
politics of that going on but look he
testified and he's been very honest that
he got a phone call from mark meadows
and donald trump that he recorded and
during the phone call donald trump said
can we just find 15 000 votes among
friends that's all and if you don't do
it it was like extortion if you don't do
it
you know bad things could happen
including jail you know
and so
the question is is that an unlawful
interference with the election process
in the state of georgia by a pres a
sitting president clinging to power to
try to get the secretary of state to
change the outcome of the election yes
or no this is not very hard for the for
the grand jury to either grasp those
concepts
um or to or to indict so
i'm still holding out hope that phony
willis puts on that evidence and that
gets that grand jury do you think do you
think though that that case could go
from being a georgia state case to being
a federal case i mean is that a
possibility so so what you're saying is
if he's indicted in georgia because
georgia's interest is to protect their
elections right speaking of states
rights like states do have rights to
protect their interests their interest
would be uh georgia gabe do you have a
question about the state's rights in new
york with uh with the 10 thousand the
ten thousand dollars a day in contempt
well i mean i think what uh what are we
at right now we're at a hundred and
because it counts the weekend so we're
like one third yes i want to say it's
every it's every single day right it's
right yeah it's all natural days he
doesn't get a break in the week no no
yeah it's not just weekdays it's it is
seven days a week that thing even when
he's golfing even when he's gone yeah
it's an expensive day of golf
but yeah you you look at like you look
at georgia right yeah it's like 11 780
votes find them right it's very much the
same like to comey
i'm looking for loyalty here right like
that's the same you know it's uh
i'm not
uh forcing this on you but i'm forcing
it on you you know that's like the well
i will see you
did it you did it exactly right it's the
call to comey it's the call to to
zielinski to hold back 450 million
dollars in aid unless a hunter biden
investigation and prosecutor is open
it's the same
there's no doubt like trump couldn't
listen to this and go that's not me i
don't do those things right all he does
i mean i think you could you could you
could play back the tape and he would be
so egotistical he'd be like yeah that's
me i said those things like he would
totally brag about it because he was
like i love the sound of my own voice
right like that's the type of guy which
is insane to think about just from a
standpoint to be like we had a president
who did multiple times tried to
influence someone by holding something
back from them you know like oh which is
called distortion right exactly it's
like a little quick pro quo here you do
this i do this right
it is insane to think that we had a
present like that and then so you look
at
georgia i hope that you know they they
assemble the grand jury and we actually
have a case there you look at uh you
look at new york you you've got the ten
thousand dollars a day you look at you
know leticia james who's saying like i'm
gonna announce legislation to expand the
abortion access which would go against
right everyone's like oh states rights
well the state is acting in their own
right to protect the women that they
feel should have this right that you
took away this
fake fantasy right like again to go back
it goes back to the earlier statement
which was like
does that mean all the other rights are
fantasy rights like everyone's like i'm
a constitutionalist so you believe in
slavery you
believe women shouldn't vote like
actually slavery was in the constitution
right right right yeah yeah right right
now yeah the right to own other human
beings that was in our country that was
in our constitution exactly but like you
said like the the constitution is an
organism it is a living growing document
that is meant to be amended is meant to
evolve like everyone who says
the otherwise i think are ignorant or
don't know anything about our history as
a country or the purpose of the document
but
isn't that but isn't that the kind of
the the crux of this of this fascist
state that they want it's like well we
want to just interpret the words that
are there and only the words that are
there that way we can dial back as far
as we want is that kind of right when
you when you you're exactly right when
you and gabe's right to when you start
from
the premise that the federalist society
which all of these judges
have kissed the ring of in order to
advance in their careers from law school
clerkships federal lower federal court
judge judge positions and now the
supreme court the fealty that they
showed to the federalist society starts
and ends with the following concept
that you you only interpret the
constitution based on the literal text
of the constitution with reference when
it helps you to history
and not even our history yeah third 14th
century history 17 16th century history
on abortion
who gives a [ __ ] what medieval what
medieval people
who also believed in leeches
burning witches at the stake
putting them on racks in order to grow
them i mean who cares what a medieval
primitive people
thought about when life was conceived
this is the problem that's always been
present in the abortion right in the
right to choose the problem is the
science that was baked into the original
decision
if they could have uncoupled the science
in brennan in uh in the casey in 1992
and they said look we're judges we're
not scientists we're not medical
professionals we're going to find that
under the right of privacy the
interpretation of the constitution
bodily autonomy that there is a right
for a woman to terminate
whatever is inside her embryo fetus etc
at the appropriate time we're going to
leave the appropriate time to the
medical profession
maybe to the states to regulate
and that's going to be it
that that's in line with everything else
they don't legislate the exact way that
a state regulates gun control they don't
say if it goes too far they'll find it
unconstitutional but they don't say
there and the constitution provides that
there shall be an id process and that
there shall be a cooling off and waiting
period that's left to the states why the
abortion right
hasn't just been declared to be we don't
like the science we can't figure it out
but there is a right and we'll leave it
to the states to regulate how that right
but it is a right gets executed here
they just said the science sucks it
sucked from the very beginning
and we and we are making a decision that
that should have been left to the states
we're ripping the right away and that's
it
that's only because they go back to
historically
not to current precedent current
precedent is these people have had the
right for over 50 years
and look at the ramification lower
abortion rates
more acceptance of abortion
and safer
that was the problem the problem is
women will get an abortion one way or
another to terminate an unwanted
pregnancy i thought we didn't want them
dying in underground clinics garages and
back alleys
we don't we don't we actually care for
another living person or a human being
as opposed to
republicans who might would you know
again republicans claim you know whether
it's under christianity or whatever
they're like i love i love thy neighbor
you know i will shelter you i will care
for you i will i will do all these
things for you and
until they need one or they're getting
it and their kid needs one and then
they're on a flight to new york or
california which i don't worry about to
go get you know how many of these many
of these people have i don't know what
your audience is going to say about this
do they believe that out of 537 people
in the u.s congress there's not one
affair going on oh really yeah there's
no there's not one or or cocaine field
sex orgies i mean come on or a pregnancy
that somebody doesn't really want right
and what are they going to do that
because they're rich and famous they get
to go offshore or they get to go to a
state like new york and california
we should pass laws that say no no
elected official who voted against roe v
wade or any of them can ever go into our
state to have an abortion how about that
so so so that's that's one the
the second thing is when it when it
comes to uh when it comes to abortion
and the right and the right to choose no
one's pro-abortion this is why the
language has always been pro-choice and
then they took pro-life
it's not like i'm it's not like i'm
anti-life
right okay it's not like i'm
pro-abortion or any of the people that
support it we're pro a woman's right to
choose
right and we're against government
compelled forced pregnancy to term
that is what this word or to death i
mean here's the organization
right because because we're talking
about uh because the science is not is
not out on this one like we know we know
that it is a clump of cells you people
out there still claiming that life
begins when the dude gets his oh face is
absolutely ridiculous and and you sound
ridiculous and the more ridiculous you
get the less support you're going to
have and this decision is the most
ridiculous turning back and to think
that they're going to stop in red states
because this is this is the nonsense
that that i think is um this is the
nonsense that they're going to stop here
right with red states oh we're giving
states rights and only and only the
states that want to ban abortion are
going to ban it that's all [ __ ]
they're not going to stop there they're
not going to stop their march to get rid
of women's rights because this is truly
not pro-life it is anti-woman
they do not want women to have the
autonomy over their bodies it has
nothing to do with the fetus it has
nothing to do with the baby they don't
give a [ __ ] about children in this
country if they did they would do
something and get off their asses about
child hunger we'll do it we'll do it
this way you do it this way
um if if this was uh i forget if it was
a schwarzenegger movie if men could
carry babies too oh that's what i was
talking about or
embryos or fetuses do you think this law
would have come down let's do that
you think these old white guys would
have come down with they would have
found a way at their golf courses and
country clubs to come up with a way to
save the right to choose if it impacted
them or forced sterilization or forced
vasectomies if that was up for grabs
look i knew we were in trouble during
the oral argument when amy coney barrett
who never who was never a judge who was
only a notre dame catholic law professor
you mean she was unqualified
is that what you're saying who has seven
children
when she who who believes in her and by
the way i'm fine with believing in your
faith somebody on your somebody on your
channel i don't know who it is um
i don't know they implied that i'm the
devil i was like speaking of the devil
here's popock all right
great great
we love having the devil by the way the
devil is the devil is pro-choice i'm
just gonna i'm just gonna put that out
there yeah right you know start that
twitter trend all right now
now having s having said that i don't
even know where i was
having said that
amy coney bear at handmade amy cody
barrett during the oral argument
i mean totally apropos of nothing like
from beyond left field like from a whole
another planet
actually asked her question i think she
asked one
yeah aren't there places where a baby
can be dropped off like at firehouses
i'm like okay stop
okay stop
so
because there are
there are laws on the books and there
are in most states that allow a woman
who's given birth to a child that she
does not want without any questions
asked to as long as the child's not
jeopardized to kind of leave it on a
doorstep
that is the substitute for a woman's
autonomy and right to choose well she's
just taking it back to moses you know
she's like put it in the thing drop it
down the river well that was saturday
night live right i thought i thought she
did a great job
did a great job as amy coney barrett
just do your nine just do your nine
months drop drop the baby what's the big
deal right yeah
drop it did you guys seen the opening
the cold open it was it was it was a
good cold open it was a good cold open
which is it is it is you know it comes
back to one of these things where it's
like
they're not making anything up obviously
they're exaggerating some jokes but this
is literally oh let me let me call on
this old
thing that was done from medieval times
and i'm gonna quote this as something
that should be used in 2022. and then
why don't you quote all the things from
medieval times right yeah exactly
people people popping in right now tony
are probably thinking are they talking
about the place with the big turkey legs
medieval times
no
well what they want to take us back to
medieval times and let me let me prove
it to you before you go popak i've got a
clip that i like to play here um
constantly and the reason why is because
he really is the leader of messaging of
the republican party you've heard of the
america first um language right you've
heard of america first language of
course uh uh pretty sure charles
lindbergh used that it's and it's also a
pro-nazi language marjorie taylor green
and uh
uh
matt gates charlie kirk and
they should look up the history of
america first and when it was first used
in this country
and maybe
maybe they did look it up and they're
like yep this is exactly yeah that's us
so this is this is nick fuentes do you
know nick fuentes is uh he actually has
this little logo down here at the bottom
it's called america first this is the
this is the guy who's an anti-semite he
holds nazi rallies and he calls them
america first rallies and he's the guy
at the ny uh
the fdny was in the news this weekend
for america first guys yelling at
protesters this is that guy this is his
their leader this is the guy that
marjorie taylor well if i could get it i
think we have copyright infringement on
af by the way that looks like
that looks like my legal language uh oh
well popock the lawyer's on it here he's
he's gonna file a brief listen so so
this person nick fuentes is the one that
marjorie taylor green went to his rally
um his nazi rally and she spoke and then
she didn't know him she couldn't recall
you know she didn't recall a lot of
things but i want to show you what nick
fuentes their their master of messaging
here has to say about women and
abortions and what the punishment should
be listen very carefully the woman
should be put in jail too they should
all go to jail a hundred years for the
doctor a thousand years for the woman
that's what i say this is their master
of messaging pope why is it always a guy
that looks like he's never had sex in
his life he hasn't he's never had he's
never it's always
i've been choosing since i was in the
fifth grade right right
is there anything you'd like to plug
before you go i know you probably have
to bounce here soon what would you like
to plug plug anything that you'd like oh
all right thank you so uh every
wednesday and saturdays we do legal af
on the midas dutch network where we look
at similar to what we're doing here but
we sometimes we bring in some guests we
look at six or eight
um real-time stories from that week at
the intersection of law and politics
that's our wheelhouse that's our lane
and
i either do it with ben misalis one of
the founders of midas touch a civil
rights lawyer
along with me or i do with the midweek
edition which is a slightly shorter
edition with karen friedman eknifolo a
former prosecutor in the manhattan da's
office and we really look at every story
from abortion anything trump jan 6
anything related to
you know things that are in the news
that are really important the
prosecution of the gen 6 people and we
and we call it like it is if we call
balls and strikes we don't blow smoke or
sunshine we do it from a democratic
progressive standpoint no doubt but you
know i'm there you know to really
um get under the hood and tell our
listeners what the facts are our
audience so they can go out into the
streets and with bull horns or otherwise
and debate these issues with real
knowledge and real facts we have
on the twitter community we have a legal
af twitter community that people can
join where i post
information in in and out of each show
could be the actual lawsuit it could be
the decision the order the leaked order
whatever it is we'll put it all there so
thanks for letting me do the plug and
you know we love coming on this show too
yeah well uh as everyone knows out there
we simulcast to the mind as touch
facebook page and pop i know you're you
appear over there several times a week
on the midas touch facebook page as well
to their other properties um so go go
follow legal af go download it um go to
facebook go to youtube watch legal af
and our our listeners know you and they
also know kfa um you know kfa came and
she helped us um break down the marjorie
taylor green hearing that day so anyone
who wants to go watch kfa do that um
we've got that on our youtube channel
just go the tony michael's podcast on
youtube and see kfa do that but go
follow legal af um it's worth watching
did i hear or did you tell me pre uh
pre-party that uh
you're gonna be doing the uh jan six
committee hearings or real
gavel to gavel in june is that true
it sounds it sounds like well me and
gabe uh want to live stream just like we
did the marjory taylor green with
commentary that um um that day we want
to do that for the public hearings of
the jan six so our plan is to live
stream the jan six with commentary um
from gavel to gavel to make sure that
the not just um our audience sees the
hearing itself but also gets live
commentary so we would love to have you
kfa and and ben
from legal af come and give us the some
of the legal breakdown as those
as those hearings uh uh
go on and we live stream them um just
like we did the marjory taylor green so
you're you are welcome to come and and
give us your commentary yeah i'd love to
do that yeah we i watched it i watched
it with karen
and i know uh and ben would do it too so
i think we'll it's gonna be
a week-long
must-watch tv for democracy for for the
republic's survival
i know everybody i know the marjorie
taylor greens and the republicans and
some of them are watching the show are
like i loved your comment it was only
one day
it was just one day it was just one
insurrection in one day that's all right
like pearl harbor
no like corrupt like hiroshima was one
day right right harbor
just one day
right yeah well yeah you know one day at
a time i guess so we'll we'll get to the
bottom of it with the jan6 public
hearing so audience out there listening
pop is just broke news here on the tony
michael's podcast is we will be
streaming live the public jan six
hearings uh from the select committee in
popeye now sounds like he's gonna be
joining us sounds like i'm gonna yeah
i'm gonna join i'm gonna have to join
you that's fantastic that's fantastic
well we look forward we look forward to
those hearings and you joining us in
your commentary uh audience stick around
we got more for you with the tony
michaels podcast pop thanks for coming
on we always enjoy having you back tell
everyone here thank you yeah
tell everyone at legal af we said hi
okay oh we will thank you everyone stick
around we'll be right back after thanks
guys good luck thank you cheers another
video i want to show you gabe that uh
everyone's been circulating around you
know lee mcgowan politics girl she has a
podcast on minus touch uh we're proud
partners of of midas touch um she did a
video
and uh i wanna she's also
gonna be on i i'm hoping i'm hoping i'm
hoping um that we can get leon to do
commentary uh so folks out there that
are lee mcgowan politics girl fans let
her know that do you want to hear her
her her live commentary
uh for the public hearings uh for the
select january 6th select committee um
coming up in the next month so
um definitely give her a shout out there
to say that you want to hear her
commentary but here is a little bit of
her commentary on the current issues
stop saying the democrats are just going
to lose you know the entire world said
the ukrainians were just going to lose
but it was inevitable that russia was
just too strong too big too powerful
well that was [ __ ] the ukrainians
cared more they fought back they were
told to surrender and they said hey
russian worship go [ __ ] yourselves and
that is what those of us who love
democracy have to say that's the energy
we have to embrace hey republican party
go [ __ ] yourselves you think you can
cheat and steal and lie and win you
think you could just take our rights
from us and our vote from us and our
freedoms from us and we're just gonna
let you i don't think so yeah i wish the
democrats could get their [ __ ] together
and put together a messaging platform
that makes sense that speaks to the
moment but if they can't we're just
going to have to do it without them just
like the brave ukrainian citizens
thought back from their own windows and
made their own
cocktails and acted like the [ __ ]
ballers that they were democratic voters
are not just gonna give up because
everyone says we're gonna lose i'm
fighting for democracy for my own
goddamn kitchen and i know i'm not alone
this country is filled with patriots who
won't just give up democracy without a
fight we are not going to lose we can't
lose we have to come out in droves and
convince our people to come out in force
to vote against this sad pathetic
backwards racist homophobic xenophobic
misogynistic [ __ ] party banning
books and gays and women's rights this
anti-democratic party without values or
morals who wants to take your social
security and your medicare and to fund
our public schools and raise taxes on
the poor how can people even consider
voting for them what are they even
offering
we have to decimate this party and then
we have to start the hard work of
building up a country we can all be
proud of one that works for everyone
which is exactly what they are fighting
so hard to avoid but this change only
happens with the democrats the one party
who still believes in democracy i think
the republican party is bitten off more
than they can chew just like the
russians i think they've overplayed
their hand they think they're
untouchable but even with all their
cheating and lying and gerrymandering we
have to show them that they will never
defeat the idea of a free america with
liberty and justice for all
hey russian warship
go [ __ ] yourselves
[Laughter]
oh my god
she always has a way of packing like we
do 10 hours worth of content here every
single week and i feel like that we try
to convey this message every single week
and she has a way of packing it into two
minutes
oh thank you lee for fighting for
democracy from your kitchen from your
microphone now i've been giving people
the messaging so subscribe to politics
girl go follow lee everywhere you can um
and listen her breakfast rant videos are
are fantastic as far as messaging is
concerned um gabe this is this is an
important and important time yeah
and not just like to start this process
today but like tomorrow
next week next month we can't afford
to start this process and that is why it
is so important for people to yell and
scream in the streets even if it means
holding a bullhorn
in front of brett kavanaugh's house
um it is time to do that speaking of
wearing out over time
i don't know you know i transition
um what do you think about what's your
opinion on these protests in front of
these justices houses apparently
uh i
this is what i think i think
that people complaining about people
showing up to kavanaugh's house a house
i i i
i think it's totally fine i think it's
totally fine they're just getting into
little good trouble they're not causing
any harm right obviously that's that's a
problem right there but if you look at
if you look at brett kavanaugh and every
one of these other supreme court
justices that are trying to or or
republicans the gop they are violating
other people's rights right it only it
starts here and it's going to continue
on to where it's like oh i'm going to go
into your house because
uh
we you know we believe we heard
that uh you were pregnant and we don't
get you know an abortion i'm not saying
it'll go that far but i am saying like
the extreme of feeling violated in your
own home imagine how a woman feels their
own body feels violated because they do
whatever means now have to have a child
that they don't want they don't don't
feel like they have the resources or
they don't have the the proper support
to help raise so they say i want an
abortion there's nothing wrong with that
but according to the gop in the supreme
court
yeah they're just uh
they have to have the kid right what did
what did lido say he said domestic uh
domestic supply of infants well i mean
you know you gotta have inventory gabe
you gotta have inventory
and we can't we can't we can't we can't
have people being loud
on public sidewalks in front of
justice's houses that is just
intolerable in this country we cannot
have people holding megaphones and
saying things that make these fascists
uncomfortable get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ] look and frankly frankly
they're trying to equate people being
loud on a street in front of a justice's
house because they're trying to strip
away people's rights away from them
right
equating it to an insurrection look if
it were the insurrection people would be
going to the supreme court they would be
breaking down the doors breaking windows
uh erecting a gallows in front of the
supreme court and threatening to hang
the justices they are not doing that
that is not a thing they're doing
they're not going in the supreme court
they're not are you saying that these
people are actually protesting yes
you know what scares do you know what
terrifies fascists do you know what
terrifies them absolutely free speech
terror yeah yeah and protest
i mean it is it is a thing that
absolutely terrifies him and has for
years and someone sent me anonymous has
this uh i want i want to play this
anonymous uh posted this video from
telecomics canada um
i'm not sure it is a rendition of woody
guthrie do you know woody guthrie is you
know what he got three is
the name sounds familiar so woody
guthrie is a folk music
um he wrote folk music and he had a
guitar and the guitar on the guitar it
says
this machine kills fascists he wrote do
you know the song this land is your land
oh yes this land is my land
from the new york islands i i'm from
beginning it wrong
right so that that is that that woody
guthrie song
is a response to
um
god bless america right so uh woody
guthrie wrote that song in response to
um
god bless america but here's the thing
here's the thing is he also wrote a song
said
um all you fascists are bound to lose
all you fascist are bound to lose and
here is a great rendition that anonymous
had posted of all you fascists are bound
to lose let's listen
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you know i know a lot of hillbillies
right because i'm in ozark so i know a
lot of hillbillies which is a specific
specific type of redneck but the midwest
field is a little different i would
break it like i would see like people
tend to lump in white trash hillbilly
red right i think those are three
different types of people absolutely you
know like it's you could break it down
by what they drive
white trash is like a trans am type guy
but you know with like two different
colored fenders of course yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's but then like a you know a
redneck or a hillbilly that's more of a
truck you know but then like
hillbilly hillbilly's like a lifestyle
as opposed to like redneck is an
attitude if that makes sense right yeah
yeah yeah yeah well i i know plenty of
hillbillies for sure i mean um i i at
some points in my life i is one right
like
like i'm from i'm from the ozarks i grew
up at the lake of the ozarks where the
netflix series ozarks is is shot yeah so
um i is one at to some degree so i agree
with you that hillbilly is definitely
a lifestyle and redneck can be an
attitude because a hillbilly can be a
redneck is that what you're saying and a
redneck doesn't necessarily they're not
necessarily a hillbilly oh yeah are you
guys is this like a square can be a
rectangle but a rectangle can't be a
square
yeah absolutely 100 don't ask me to give
you more examples past the one i gave
you because
that premise might break down all the
pro starvers out there they're not pro
lifers anymore they're pro starvers save
the clump of cells starve the children
that's the republican party's motto and
this isn't new it is not republicans
wanting to starve children is not a new
concept they've always been against wic
a bank against snap against the food
stamps part of the farm bill they've
always always been against children
getting food in this country especially
food that could give them nutrition and
save their lives i mean as george carlin
said it best if you're pre-born you're
fine if you're preschool you're [ __ ]
this is not a new concept that the
republicans want to starve children
especially
especially brown children oh boy they
really they really are for that because
you know it says in the bible starve the
brown children because
baby formula biden's fault let's go
brandon nazis
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] em
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking